[applause]
nothing
[music]
knocking
there is a
sound Not yet yet there is
Maxim Listen 1 2 3 4 5 1 2 3 1 2 3
everything is fine 1 2 3 1 2 3 4 5 6 7
recording
[applause]
[music]
Moscow March 30  23 years
in which, in relation to Hercegovich, on
26.10.91, the year of birth,
I will take you there is not yet a crime
to be provided for here
[music]
one month 29 days
May 29, 23, advice materials are presented
to be tapped
[music]
it is necessary to order sir without
changing
[music]
articles 389  13 20 28 of the Code of Criminal Procedure of the Russian Federation ruled the
decision of the Lefortovsky District Court of the City of
Moscow, on March 30, 23, the
detention to leave
unchanged the operational complaints of lawyers
business satisfaction figure leave
it can be appealed to the essence in the
catalization instance in accordance with the article of the
order established by chapter 47 of
the hair rate of the Russian
Federation  remember with the decision the
established dragon term will be made his
coffee will be if translated into
English the gershors inside the other
participants in the process can get connections the
districts can also get acquainted with
the minutes of the meeting selling you
notice
at this court session is closed Thank you
all Goodbye need to be translated
Thank you